a meeting of NATO leaders in London is
on to mark the Alliance's 70th
anniversary it's got underway on to an
acrimonious start u.s. President Donald
Trump declared that the United States
gets the least benefit from NATO he met
NATO secretary-general Jens Stoltenberg
ahead of the meeting which aims to
discuss issues including defense
financing Russia and a threat to cyber
security from China President Trump also
lashed out at the French president
Emmanuel macron after the French leader
accused NATO of being brain-dead nobody
needs more than France you just look
back over the last long period of time
nobody needs NATO more than friends and
frankly the one that benefits really the
least is the United States we benefit
the least we're helping Europe Europe
unites and they go against a common foe
that may or may not be a foe can tell
you that but there are other folks out
there also but I think nobody needs it
more than friends and that's why I think
that when friends makes a statement like
they made about NATO it's a very
dangerous statement for them to make
their son go to our correspondent Tara
shows who's following the story for us
from London welcome Terry now even
before the meeting has got underway this
acrimony especially between the US and
France wanted Donald Trump's comments
tell us about his commitment to NATO
well I'm Rita it would take me a while
to fact-check that sound bite that you
just used even though I think we should
do that and you know I think that even
some of the Baltic allies will be taking
issue with what President Trump said
because it's not in their interest that
he's saying that France is the one that
needs the alliance most that the truth
is that every one of the 29 members
needs the Alliance needs to be able to
know that article 5 is solid and that
they will all come to its defence if
threatened so I think that this this
statement alone will be something that
is discussed quite intensely he
at NATO today but this isn't the only
tension in in the the weeks and months
leading up to this meeting there is also
of course the events that made president
Milan say that NATO is brain dead and
that was the u.s. decision to abruptly
pull out of northern Syria while two of
its allies Britain and France had boots
on the ground there so of course there
are many many issues that need to be
discussed and in fact one of president
McMahon's points was that NATO should be
the place where it's done that of course
means that everything is not going to go
smoothly and tarry another contentious
issues at Turkey's president richard tab
edwin is threatening to block the NATO
defense initiative involving Balkan
countries what does richard pryor
edom hope to achieve and really get it
this is a longer-term issue because the
initiative expanding the response plan
for the Baltics is not actually on the
table here it's not going to be part of
what is hoped to be a final document
here but Turkey has been threatening to
block an expanded war fighting plan to
defend the Baltic States unless he gets
more support on on the issue of
declaring Kurdish groups as terrorist
groups now as we know the United States
is one of the countries that considers
some terror some Kurdish groups as
allies in northern Syria and already the
US defense secretary on his way here to
London has said that's not going to
happen so it remains to be seen whether
turkey pushes that issue even further
now now that that initiative is is not
on the table but it's just one of the
the issues that it is going to come up
with turkey of course turkey has this
russian-made
defense system that it shows over those
produced by NATO allies and that's
something that the United States is
still very very concerned about so if
air Dewan is trying to push allies to
support him on some issues he's going to
have a lot of a lot of resistance coming
from other countries on some of these
other issues that are very very serious
Entebbe NATO leaders are there to mark
or even celebrate the Alliance's 70th
anniversary but listening to you and all
the divisions we are seeing in recent
times does it indicate that in fact NATO
needs to re in
vent itself to make itself more relevant
to the new realities of the world yes
not the way anybody would like to
imagine their birthday being celebrated
with all of these issues coming up and
and some of the allies themselves
seeking to criticize the Alliance rather
than to make it seem stronger that of
course is something NATO
secretary-general Jens Stoltenberg
constantly says that despite all of
these problems were stronger together
than apart and I think that it is a fair
criticism that NATO needs to constantly
reinvent itself because think about the
external threats that it's facing from
cyber from space from a constantly
evolving Russia from China it does need
to constantly reinvent itself and it
shouldn't take that as as something that
means it's not relevant in fact if NATO
does choose to to sort of reconfigure
itself to be a platform where all kinds
of issues are discussed openly I think
that that makes it more relevant for the
future even than it was in the past
perhaps but it remains to be seen
whether it can do that right teri
Schultz in London thank you very much
for this update from there Yin
Stoltenberg needs no reminder that
today's world is much more complex than
the simple East versus West of the Cold
War years the NATO chief has stressed
the continuing danger posed by terror
groups in the Middle East so
jeopardizing their gains we are made in
the fight against the ISIS and that's
exactly the reason why when the other
the NATO defence ministers share few
days ago they all agreed that we need to
maintain the progress we are made in the
fight against ours
but the Alliance is deeply split NATO
cornerstone the u.s. staged a surprise
policy u-turn by pulling most of its
troops out of Syria that cleared the way
for Turkey another NATO member but
working with Russia to launch an
offensive into northern Syria even
before that turkey had irritated its
NATO allies by buying Russian
surface-to-air missiles now Russia has
become turkey's closest ally in one of
the world's most volatile regions
funding is another contentious issue
u.s. president Donald Trump has
repeatedly railed against NATO's
European members most of which failed to
meet the agreed defense spending target
70 is on from its foundation the NATO
alliance is feeling its age